hi guys welcome to the just curly things
youtube channel
today i'm going to be doing let's take
this out of the background
um today i'm going to be doing something
a little bit
different so there was a comment on one
of my videos okay
it said if you're not careful you will
become
red pill on accident listening to this
content
i don't know what red pill is
so today i'm going to be investigating
[Music]
i would say live but the live isn't
working but like it'll be like you're
live because i'm
too lazy to edit this so
i started by googling okay red pill
on youtube and
this is what i'm finding oh wait but
before i start do not forget to like
comment subscribe as you guys know i'm
trying to move out of my parents house
and it's been rough
actually i kind of like it here but i
feel like i should move out at some
point anyways
i'm about to start what is the red pill
about okay sounds working sorry guys
i always listen when i'm not reacting
live i listen to everything on like
3x speed because i'm impatient
okay implicit language ooh i'm so
scared i was able to get a girlfriend
for you know for the most part she was
nice and didn't quite work out
i had you know blamed myself i
simultaneously blamed her and
i couldn't get any guidance from my
friends or my family about this
and i googled how do i get my girlfriend
back i was just you know that
that distraught he was a regular guy
with some relationship
issues but he entered a place a frame of
mind
he rejected what he was told about
society a lot of you know cults you know
they look for
people who are in transitional periods
of their lives as soon as they see their
vulnerability they take it
a search for dating advice can spiral
into political radicalization
was it just that you felt lonely or
misunderstood
combination of both that was essentially
like my gateway drug
this is giving me no information
none like what is red pill to the whole
concept that feminism was my enemy
so what happened to him our world has
become a chat room
i think in many ways we have become our
avatars we have become
offline the people that we are online
the definition of truth is shifting
the internet is a gateway that allows us
to choose which reality we want to live
in
okay that's stupid because what do you
mean which reality
there's only one reality but what
i think she's referring to is different
opinions right
like you choose which opinions you
listen to
some people listen to the left some
people listen to the right
some people don't like the internet at
all it's a choice
sense of community a sense of you know
brotherhood fit into that losing that
hate and that anger and that depression
frustration internet memes break through
the screen
they draw people in with irreverence and
irony a lot of people will start being
ironically racist before they start
being really racist
this is a story of two realities
you take the blue pill the story ends
you wake up in your bed and believe
whatever you want
okay this is not helping me at all so
like 10 minutes okay what
is the red pill
okay
um which video should i do let's pick
this one what's up bulldogs in this
video i'm gonna be telling you what is
the red pill and why
so many mgtow get it wrong
okay i got a comment on one of my videos
about how to get big biceps
okay and he says i saw your elliott
roger video can you do one
video on red pill so i thought well sure
i could do a video on red pill if you're
just joining me for the first time i'm
john from bulldogmindset.com
on this channel i teach you how to have
the bulldog mindset the bulldog mindset
is the opposite of the victim mindset
the bulldog mindset takes responsibility
for your own actions and teaches you to
empower yourself by developing mental
toughness
stoic wisdom from the ages and to really
just become a stronger better version of
yourself
what's happened now i think is that
there's been a lot of factions
i would say a lot of divisions of what
was originally uh
one kind of unified idea behind this red
pill kind of thinking
and and the red pill thinking comes from
the matrix right it comes from that
you know neo right morpheus thing where
you take the blue pill
and you can go back to your normal life
and forget everything on the red pill
and you see how far the rabbit hole goes
and so this whole concept of being red
pilled is
seeing the uncomfortable truth about
society
specifically about women why do we need
to be
quote red pulled and what does this
exactly mean okay well the reason why
is because a lot of guys okay especially
in today's society today
they've kind of been brought up with the
whole disney romantic notion
of love stories and uh and they have
misconceptions about the female
psychology
and how women act and how to get women
that
seems like the right thing to do but
it's not because they don't understand
the psychology
of women they don't understand the
biological process that led us
evolutionary
evolution wise to where we are what ends
up happening is a lot of these guys
they end up either being quote forever
alone and
and being dig dejected by by women and
never
uh finding their quote true love or they
end up you know getting into
relationships
and being you know basically like this
this guy that is taken advantage of
that doesn't get sex anymore that you
know doesn't
doesn't know what he's doing wrong okay
so i think
he's talking about men without backbones
so basically like if a man doesn't know
how to stand up for himself he ends up
getting walked over
by women and by society this is let me
know in the comments right wrong
and is maybe eventually cheated on and
left and
and all these these bad things that
happened because the
the woman is not really attracted to
this this guy and he doesn't understand
why he's buying her gifts he's buying
her flowers he's being the nice guy and
that's how most people think
where did the term red pill come from it
came from
most you know mostly we contribute this
to roller tomassie's book the rational
mail which
all of you guys should read that book
okay i caveat this
by saying that it's a little bit jaded
but it's it's mostly not
okay it's mostly just a book that i
would recommend i think his viewpoint is
is slightly more jaded than what mine
is okay but it's mostly a positive book
in terms of just getting you to face and
understand the reality well what about
loyalty what about
all the years and the time that i put in
there and and the sacrifices i made
it doesn't matter because hypergamy is a
biological
type of of a programming okay
that is very very difficult to overcome
women are going to
want to do this because it is going to
ensure the survival of the human race
the way i'm
presenting this okay when i talk about
red pill stuff
is in a very neutral way okay i hope you
can see i don't have any
animosity about these things the point
is that it's just nature
it's just what happened the issue that i
have right now
okay with a lot of where mgtow and
manosphere has gone in and there was a
guy
that was on this channel when i did some
video and he sent his whole army to
call me a [ __ ] and a soy boy and all
this [ __ ] okay
this is not good okay because it's
vengeful okay this is this is nature
this is society this is reality
okay and the reality is and there's a
lot of this of this kind of red pill
thinking
in roller tomassie's book okay
so it seems like this is is this saying
how to like get
girls in the rational male is that
society
is mostly become a very kind of
social justice leftist place where
political correctness is kind of stamped
out
and it and you know bigger bigger
government
is more beneficial to women into
feminist ideals that's how it's become
and it had to sort of become that way
because that creates stability it
creates
a situation where women are no longer
dependent on men
financially for a lot of things they can
become independent so they can
act and behave in ways that wouldn't
have been
socially acceptable before okay that
could be interpreted as
cruel okay but they're not okay it's
just a natural
behavior and it's adaptation to the time
do i like some of these things
no i'm not going to like some of these
things but it is
it's it's the where the pieces on the
board are at this particular time
red pill awareness or being red pill is
in my mind okay being aware of the
situation
doesn't mean you like it it doesn't mean
that you hate it okay
it's that you're neutral to it and you
say okay it's just like this
if i give you a chess board and i give
you the pieces and they are in some kind
of arrangement
okay you could like i could give you a
position to play and you could be upset
because you're in a bad losing position
you don't like the way the board is
arranged or
you can just objectively say okay well
this is where it's at and
this is my best move at this point with
what i've got okay
and that's life that's how it is because
it doesn't matter how angry or upset we
are about society again you have it on
both sides you have the kind of like
feminist social justice warriors and
those people
they want to uh embrace the victim
mindset and change
society and the way that they think it
should be changed
they don't want to empower people and
empower themselves and solve their own
problems and deal with reality as it is
they want to change other people's
behavior they want okay so what he's
saying is that you should have the
mindset of no matter what hand you're
dealt no matter how bad you have it this
is the way society is
and the red pill is like opening your
eyes to the way society is
and the left i think
or the society what he's referring to
like the feminists whatever
they're the ones saying that society
shouldn't be like this
you guys tell me if i'm right or if i'm
wrong in the comments you guys know
i'm pretty open-minded so you guys let
me know what you think
you're bad you're wrong toxic
masculinity okay wrong you're doing bad
things shame
shame shame okay me too me too
shame shame shame whatever not saying
that bad things don't happen or wrong
needs to happen i'm just saying that
their solution okay is to shame and
change people and mold people to what
they want
thinking that the bad things will go
away it's the same
thing on the extreme mgtow side a lot of
guys that
got this kind of red pill concept they
think they're red pills now they're not
red pill
because they're not seeing reality
clearly they're actually like somewhere
over in the spectrum i'm not gonna give
other pill colors here but
i talked about this in another video
where i talked about black pill and all
this stuff but
but basically what they've done is
they're doing the same thing they want
to change
society and women okay they want them to
stop
being hyper gamers they want them to be
whatever it is what they want women to
be
right they want society to stop
being feminists okay they want all these
things they want
again to take the victim mindset because
when you say that
the reason why um you know that i can't
get a relationship
or all this stuff is because women are
[ __ ] because society teaches them
this because they have
you know uh a drive-through of [ __ ]
whatever it is and you you use all these
terms you call people
thoughts and cucks and all this stuff
what happens is you are victimizing
yourself you're
you're having the victimizer you're
saying that it's it's everyone else's
fault it's all this [ __ ] up society
and that it's wrong
and and and that's why i choose to be
angry and to be upset
right instead of just being objective
and saying okay this is reality so
to in my mind red pill is is
is towing that line okay it's not on
this side of
of being ignorant okay on either way
because you can be ignorant either way
blinded
to the truth it's about being neutral
and seeing things as they are
seeing okay biologically uh evolution
you know evolutionary there's plenty of
books on that sperm wars is a good one
you can check out that one but
essentially
there's a lot of information that we
have about evolutionary biology
that tells us why certain sexual
behaviors happen the way that they do
why society is arranged the way that
they do why women act the way that they
do why men act the way that they do
okay and and the differences between
them okay and this is
you know some of the stuff doesn't go
along with your fairy tale
idea of how things should work for
instance
one like if i could give you a red pill
truth it would be
that a lot of guys that are quote blue
pill that haven't been red pilled
they would think that what they should
do is that if they see a girl that they
like
they should kind of worship her and
shower her with
with affection and compliments and buy
her
flowers and buy her gifts and try and
take care of her
and and try to you know basically be
this really good
nice person but the problem with that is
oftentimes that comes across
desperate because
if a guy does that before he even knows
you
it would seem like he just does that for
everyone
which makes it well i don't want to say
character flaw because that's a really
nice thing to do
but it makes you feel like he just does
this for everybody and he just wants
anybody to be with him and you never
want to feel like you're with someone
that'll just be with anyone
and be a really good friend to her and
that she will like that
and and fall in love the reality is
that you should be more of
an aggressive uh more showing some
dominance
okay so a little bit of disinterest
right that you're not sure that you're
evaluating that you are
have a value yourself that you're
discriminating okay
and that um creating some sexual tension
showing the sexual side of yourself
that you desire her not just want to be
your friend
but those type of things again we could
talk about this when we go into all the
theory
of this but that's not the point the
point is to realize that
you know more so to realize that what
you thought this whole buying flowers
and candy
and and putting on a pedicel is actually
not the the way to do things right
understanding the reality of the
situation that's just like one of those
truths
people don't have the extreme would
again get lost
because i think i understand what he's
trying to say
um i'm gonna try to watch one more
so this is the second
red pill theory they always say yes
or what is the red tail okay i think
this guy
what is up my brothers from another
mother a good morning to you
it is early it is still kind of dark and
the sun will be in my face
i want to do this video today on what
the red pill
is because i get so many questions from
people in the comments
what's a red pill what's this blue pill
i don't understand
all right i think it's worth dedicating
a small conversation this we'll try to
get it done in the next 10 minutes or so
but um simply speaking the origin
of the red pill which i'll describe in a
minute is from the um
it's a classic scene from the movie the
matrix i'm not going to embed the clip
into the video because youtube doesn't
like that anymore and i've had videos
removed so
linked in the description below i'll
show it to you but if you don't have
that on
you know your mobile device or you watch
this on tv i'll briefly describe it
all it is was that scene where morpheus
and neo were sitting in that
room it's very dramatic with you know
lightning and you know thunder going off
in the background and he
basically offers neo two options you
take the blue pill
uh you go back to sleep walking through
your life everything is was it what it
always was
and uh you don't notice a difference you
take the red pill and you go down the
rabbit hole and you basically see how
far it goes and
what the truth really is um again you
know just watch the link in the
description below if you have this on a
desktop or something you can click right
now
so what does that mean to me and kind of
everybody else
out there and okay this is what i was
wondering because
that makes sense in theory but i don't
know what is it just the nice guy thing
that the other guy was talking about
that's been
adapted and you know been used and
there's
there's been a lot of different um
labels
or sorry the red pill has been slapped
as a label in many different ways i
should state actually
we saw this documentary that came out a
few years ago by cassie j
called the red pill which really isn't
what the red pill
is um you know we've seen it used by
other groups as well
and it's not necessarily always being
applied in his intention i think the
intention was
um the truth and all that
all that the red pill is really designed
to do and it's you know it's a metaphors
you take this you kind of wake up and
you see everything
as it truly is that's really all that it
is
um the thing that brings most men to my
videos to the red pill community to the
red man group broadcast that we're doing
okay funny thing even before i did this
reaction videos
like this like reaction series i found
that i watch more videos for
guys than for girls like does that does
that say something about me
like why um to people that write in the
manosphere
as blogs is usually some form of trauma
something in a man's life is
uh you know a belief is completely
shattered um
and it can be anything from you know i
thought women were sugar and spice and
all things nice to
we took our vows and said i do's until
death do us part and she still went and
banged the pool boy
um you know to other things outside of
that you know it applies to
other areas in life i believe anyway
where you just don't exclusively
say well i've been red pill sort of
thing and it's it's just has to do with
women
and understanding uh you know
intersectional dynamics
i believe it has a lot more to do with
life in general
um you know when they tell you eat this
or or scoop out this yogurt because it's
fat free
but it's laden with artificial
sweeteners and all kinds of other things
that aren't good for you
you know they've been broadcasting to
you publicly blue pill you know if you
will
eat this you'll be healthy slim and lose
weight and look good
but the truth of the matter is when
you're red pilled you know it's crap and
it's not good for you
sort of thing so um it applies to many
many different areas in life
and when you and when you wake up to the
reality of the way the world is you know
it's mostly the mainstream media it's
mostly
uh you know the indoctrination system
that we call schools the elementary
school system
um which really just kind of programs
people to behave and certain
and act a certain way to ways
uh even you know it's even embedded in
things like religion
and other elements of our lives that
essentially
get guys results that aren't fulfilling
satisfactory and don't lead them to a
place of happiness and contentment so
there is you know there is no one thing
or
one descriptive term i think if you ask
you know 20 different guys you'll
probably get pretty close to 20
different answers
okay this is why this is why i was
confused and they said
she's going to get red killed
depending on the lens in which they view
things but
how i apply it to my life to kind of
clarify to my channel if you're new to
the channel hi
i'm richard cooper i help guys become
better versions of themselves i coach
them through [ __ ] they're stuck on
uh that's what i do i've been doing it
for a few years now
um you know it it applies to
so many different things money the
creation of wealth
business entrepreneurship i mean
once you once you understand
things as they are not as you've been
told they should be
then that's when i truly think that you
become red pill and even still i mean i
still feel like an apprentice
uh i don't feel like i've mastered
anything you know a great book that i'm
that i'm going through right now i
haven't
quite finished yet it's called mastery
by robert greene and you know this
notion of the
i love robert greene um
i've never actually read his books
because i'm not really much of a reader
but i've watched like a million
interviews from him
apprenticeship uh phase you know usually
last seven years ten thousand hours
depending on how you wanna break it down
and what that looks like
but i still feel like i'm an apprentice
in this space to some degree even though
i've talked about it so much i've put
out like 500 videos most of them been
talking about
things and and uh lessons that i've
learned or even shared
some of them hard some of them easier
and i've coached hundreds of men now
that have been stuck on things that
didn't serve them um before i wrap up
um i think it's worth probably
mentioning again i've i've mentioned it
definitely before
in my series but i know that's probably
going to bring you know some new people
to this video as it's
titled you know what is a red pill um a
lot of guys will
kind of go through this phase in their
life where
their belief system shatters uh it's
it's basically called like a safe world
theory and when that safe world theory
that you have about
certain things supposedly being true and
you adhere to those rules which are
supposed to get you the results
you know be kind to girls sort of thing
and they'll love you just as you are
well how's that been working out for you
sort of thing you know
uh you know just be their friend again
you know how's that been working out for
you sort of thing you know have you been
getting the results out of life that you
want
and then when you realize that that that
safe world theory kind of shatters and
falls apart
then you've got a few choices i mean you
can keep subscribing to the medicine
that hasn't served you it hasn't gotten
you the results that you wanted you're
not you're not feeling happy in life
or you can update your beliefs and you
know sort of speak take the
you know take the new medicine you know
take the red pill and say thing see
things as they truly are
so when you see that comment in videos
or people mentioning it that's all that
it is it's not some magically woo-woo
cult or something like that or somebody
owns it or is copyrighted by anybody
it just it just is what it is so um you
know take it with a grain of salt but
just understand that
it has many applications but the
underlying
notion the underlying truth of it
essentially is
seeing things as they truly are removing
the veil the bs
the lies that you've been told the sugar
and spice and all things nice
uh you know notions and you just accept
things as they are and
once you can do that as a man anyway i
find you know when i'm talking to these
guys and coaching them
um and even for myself which i had to go
through you know
a lot of trauma a few years ago you you
start to realize that you become more
content you're happy you function better
i make more money now i've got better
relationships with people
uh i cut people loose that don't need to
be in my life
um you know there's a whole bunch of
things that typically end up happening
when somebody updates their beliefs and
become red pilled so
i'll leave it at that i didn't want to
ramble too long i think that gets the
point across if you
okay i think i understand switch to the
other
okay i think i understand what he's
saying um
basically what he's saying is like you
basically believe
oh gosh the world is one way when you're
a kid
and then you realize that it's not that
way especially with women like being too
nice to women
that doesn't get you success that seems
to be the common theme in all the videos
but let me know in the comments i'm sure
there's like some stuff i've
missed whatever let me know like is
there a video i should watch
next that'll really open my eyes to what
the red pill is
i don't know but let me know i will talk
to you guys
next time